well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
uh it's time to see them what's making
the headlines with the politics editor
for the online magazine
galdem lothian maclean and the sun's
political editor harry cole
who will be with us right through until
midnight so
front pages then let's check those out
we start with the metro
their headline pinging the changes
reacting to tweaks being made to the nhs
coveted app
with the aim of forcing fewer people to
self-isolate
on that same story the daily mail
declares pings can only get better
according to the guardian the prime
minister has shelved plans for a
so-called amber watchlist for
travel the director general of the joint
biosecurity center who would have been
pivotal
in giving advice on the matter has left
the post and is yet to be replaced
the telegraph describes boris johnson's
intervention as
saving holidays on the continent the
chancellor rishi sunak has told young
people that working from home
could harm their careers that is
according to the times
the son speaks to sasha atwood the
girlfriend of
england footballer jack grealish who
says she's received death threats
every day on social media since his
appearance in the european championships
the financial times has a story
concerning the possible takeover
of the aerospace and defense company
megit
and the star has a moose flash as they
report on a herd of dairy cows
fitted with pedometers to prove they are
happy moving around
where do they find these stories who
knows um anyway harry and moya are here
with their thoughts great to have you
here
um first of all then moya uh let's talk
about holidays uh this idea of an amber
watch list which went down
really badly with the travel industry
with some tory mps and indeed it seems
the chancellor
yes so if we take a look at the front
page of uh the telegraph particular
um we're looking at this amber watch
list which has been scrapped so the
newspapers yesterday were
all abuzz with how unpopular the amber
watch list is and surprise surprise
about 24 hours later there's been a
u-turn and
boris johnson has decided the amber
watch list is no longer coming into play
of course the travel industry are going
to be celebrating this wildly
what's interesting is there's a couple
conflicting views over who's been
responsible
for this u-turn if you look at the
telegraph headline it's pm
steps in to save holidays on the
continent but if you read reports
elsewhere
it suggests that actually it had more to
do with grant chaps uh the transport
minister and rishi sunak
who were bitterly opposed to the plan
but now they've decided they want to
keep travel as
simple as possible and they think that
will allow millions more people to go
away
uh this summer as opposed to having this
complex system i i mean the amber watch
list
who even knows what exactly that means i
mean how long do you have to quarantine
how long are you what happens when it
changes
um so i think this is going to clear
things up a lot for
prospective travelers yeah i guess the
the fear was you'd go straight to red
and straight to an expensive hotel
outside
whichever airport you're coming to um at
great cost to people obviously
telegraph pointing out that there had
been suggestions that spain
greece and france which currently has
its own lovely category
uh were also to be added to that watch
list um harry what's your view what
brought about this
this turnabout do you think
uh i don't think it can quite be a
u-turn if it was never quite announced
but it definitely
has been a bit of a mess for the last
also five days really this one's been
bubbling over and there's definitely a
sort of internal lobbying going on
it feels to me that um that the
department of health
for sure and some elements department of
transport definitely wanted to shift to
buck a little bit
because how should they have to move the
country very quickly
outside of the three-week review process
onto the red list
you can see the ministers sort of not
really wanting to get the blame for that
because there'll be a huge backlash
uh as you say if you force people into
uh force people into hotel quarantine
rather than quarantine at home
at a moment's notice i want to kind of
think how relaxing can a holiday be at
all
if you're on any of these ambulance
where you've presumably got to have a
bag ready to go at a moment's notice
to get home should you have to so
there's this almighty sort of
uh you know swings and roundabouts going
on in whitehall of whether to do this or
not
i think they they did sort of pull
stumps on it this morning and think
actually you know we've got a traffic
light system traffic lights are quite
easy to explain
are we really going to end up in in what
i think one poor junior minister who was
sent out this morning
described as a a rainbow spectrum of of
risk
so you can see them slightly trying to
just simplify things get back to where
they were
but in the middle middle of august when
there's not very much for us to write
about
it does just look a little bit dithery
yes and i suppose some people might say
given it is august and this is peak
holiday season why not review every week
and let everyone know what they're doing
not these great
long hiatuses between decisions and the
guardian slightly different take
obviously johnson ditches travel watch
list plan
amid chaos at the advisory body uh
suggesting that the uh
the head of it has gone and and has not
yet been replaced
um who knows i i mean i know labour have
been calling for
the data on which these decisions uh are
being made
to be published so we have a bit more
transparency here
we also saw the boss of heathrow today
too saying ditch the pcr tests in favor
of
natural flow tests which you can carry
out yourself but i guess the whole point
is you're trying to monitor
the variants coming into the country
which is done via the pcr test isn't it
so
you know this is this is the dilemma for
government isn't it maya
yes i mean ditching the lateral flow
test i think would be uh a big mistake
given that most of our lateral flow
tests are made by innova
um a company who have been uh they've
been in
the u.s has been advised that you've
been the lateral flow test made by them
there because they're so unreliable um
so i don't think it would help the
spread of covert at all if we ditch
lateral flow tests
um it's just interesting because you
look at this news in the guardian where
it says that claire gardner who was
head of the joint biosecurity center
left in june
as we pointed out it's now august so
that position
has um either been vacated or someone in
the interim and we have no idea who it
is there's very little transparency
around this data the decisions
who's advising on this whether anyone's
advising at all the guardian suggests
that um
the security center is now rudderless so
it just seemed just a bit chaotic the
way this entire pandemic has gone
that has been the overwhelming theme
chaos and it doesn't look like
it's changing anytime soon sadly yes um
celebratory tone in the daily mail harry
ping amber travel watchlist u-turn
ping climb down as nhs app tweaked and
ping kova cases
lowest for a month um first of all is
there some optimism
that the luring of cases is a genuine
drop
now after suggestions possibly it's
because schools are not testing
and also this nhs nhs app even
tweak um was that inevitable do you
think um
no it wasn't actually and 10 days ago
they were saying absolutely not
however you've got to see everything in
the context now of these planting
covid rates 21 000 cases reported
yesterday
that is you know nowhere near the 80 60
60 000 we were seeing
two or three weeks ago and nowhere near
the hundred two hundred thousand cases a
day that were being
predicted by some of the more doom
saying um medics who uh
sometimes grace these airwaves so i
think you've got to look at everything
through this prism now
of it is clear that the graph is going
the right way
it's not um you know we've been every
monday we come on here and talk about
this
you know what could it be that's driving
this the number of tests was down
slightly yes uh once the schools broke
up but the number of
but the number of negatives is the the
rate sorry that the cases have fallen
it's far greater proportion than than
the tests were down so that one can be
parked
um was it uh was it as some phasing out
of the sort of
artificial football bounce was were
cases worse because we were all in pubs
and houses watching football possibly
that was a worry but again the graph is
going in the right direction it has been
going in the right direction
you know on average almost consistently
now for two weeks so
this is it's this is obviously filling
people with optimism
least of all in in government so things
that did look a bit bleak like the idea
of slightly desensitizing the app to
stop it
you know so it's now instead of instead
of tracing contacts you've been in touch
with for five days
it actually goes down to two days it's
what nhs test and trace
the the sort of uh physical people
tracking
body actually ask you for for for who
you've seen the last
48 hours so just slightly bring it in
line to that some might say
hang on why wasn't it in line with that
all along but that's a debate i think
probably for another day
um but yeah look there is a there is a
feeling that there is a bit more
movement now and things can be done
because our case rates are crucially
falling
and long may it continue yeah that's
interesting isn't it uh the distinction
with the uh with the test and trace by
uh
by phone the metro also going on this
moyer as well pinging the changes
and really this was all about confidence
because presumably they have figures to
show
how many people are deleting the app in
order to carry on functioning
um whether it's their business needs
them or whatever so you've got to keep
the confidence in the system haven't you
yeah
i mean there's this isn't the metro
around 40 of adults use it
in the uk and i'd be interested to see
how um
how that figure might have changed over
the last few weeks given the amount of
reports about the
epidemic um i think there was a yougov
poll yesterday which found that ten
percent of people polled had deleted the
app
um but i also think what's interesting
is that they tweak this app to reduce
the amount of um days
that it takes in order to make get you
pinked in the first place but they
haven't actually done anything like
up the sick pay which is being called
for by people for ages
um and so there's two million workers
who who exist in
gig economy work and precarious work in
the uk who still aren't eligible for
sick pay at all
because they earn under 120 um a week
but these are the people who are most
likely to be you know working in
in industries where they're having close
contact with other people
um you know like uh delivery industries
for example
so it would make more sense if they were
taking this two-pronged approach to me
and i
do think it is it is a sticking point
that
things like sick pay have not been used
as an incentive
while they're making these tweaks the
app on the other side yes and
long been called for by many uh to be
fair um just a bit of crystal ball
gazing harry to finish off this section
you know what what happens now we talk
about some holidays then we roll into
september
talk about a booster certainly now for
over 50s
um you know what what what are the
prospects what are the plans
well i think what this summer
inadvertently i don't think
you know some people on you know the
darker realms of the internet will
suggest it's all been some big
experiment
but i think what this summer has shown
is the great news in the fact that the
uh the vaccine has severely limited the
the connection between deaths and cases
cases were nearly as high as you know at
one point uh
as as in this sort of second january
wave yet the deaths never
have have not and did not seem to be
getting anywhere near
uh death and hospitalizations i should
add getting anywhere near the level
of um uh of of of the winter
you know of last christmas and the
earlier this year so i think what we'll
see
in september is obviously when schools
go back and when the universities go
back
there is an expectation that case levels
will go back up
but it's weather that as the as the
summer months pass and as it gets colder
it gets darker and it gets wetter
and we get naturally into sort of cold
and coughs and flu season
whether that hospitalization level can
be kept down as well with those desks
can be tapped down
now yeah as you say they'd be doing
everything they can to roll out
booster jabs possibly giving flu jabs
and um
and covered third jabs to people at the
same time um
big desperate drive to get students
vaccinated fill that gap between the
under 30s who
there's still three million of them are
2.8 million i think it is now
um who haven't been jabbed so we'll see
all sorts of funky things uh
like we saw over the weekend about uber
and and deliver room people like that
encouraging voucher schemes to get
jabbed and then i think we're having a
big old round about vaccine passports
and whether they're really needed
because
actually if cases keep going in the same
direction do we really need to be
uh you know sort of messing with our
civil liberties on such a scale and
will people put up for it with that with
that in the same way they might do
if we were in the middle of a pandemic
at the height of a pandemic they might
be more willing to
to sort of you know to play ball with
the government on paperwork for for jabs
whereas if the case rates the data rates
are very low then i think you'll see
people go
no thanks yeah interesting i thought the
big debate would be about whether kebabs
are a big enough incentive to be fair
but
but not it's going to be about vaccine
fast foods
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now
lothian mclean and harry cole welcome
back to both of you harry to the ft we
go now
um the olympics uh with a curveball
really this
belarusian uh runner um desperate not to
go home
yeah obviously um as we were just saying
it feels a little bit something like out
the cold war this is sort of you know
you remember the stories of the great
you know some olympic defectors
who um you know slipped over the iron
curtain using the sport event
um to escape persecution now this is
even weird one
it's not even that she's been
particularly political in speaking out
against the uh the regime in fact she
merely criticized her coach for trying
to make her do an event that wasn't even
what she trained for and and she wrote
on instagram that she wasn't happy with
that
and all hell breaks loose it doesn't
help that the uh the last dictator in
europe as they call him son is in charge
of the olympic committee which has again
residents of uh of the old soviet era
and uh
and how that was run um but no an
astonishing tale and just um you know
the olympic committee obviously
very heavily monitoring that and good
news in the fact that she's
currently um appears safe and in hiding
yeah
a fascinating tale so too front page of
the sun moya
and this is the girlfriend of one of the
english stars who's receiving death
threats she says
yes sir sasha atwood uh she's been
talking on her youtube channel she's the
girlfriend of jack relish they have
quite a low-key relationship
but people who know know and greelish
became quite the heartfelt
during the euros and unfortunately it's
meant that uh slash has been
uh the subject of online abuse and she
says it's mostly by
young teenage girls which is really sad
and what it all comes back to
again and again is social media and how
abuse is sent on social media
and the fact it's not monitored or
regulated and it's so it's so easy to
just like send this we saw it with
you know marcus rashford and jaden
sancho and because
after the orders as well and it's that
same thing again social media does allow
an ease of abusing these high-profile
people and
something has to be done it's just the
question of what yeah exactly don't we
don't we all know it in some respects i
guess
moya harry thank you so much we'll see
you again soon thank you